- hello everybody and welcome to the H
Lee Park as experience I'm not that
wasn't shtick I just finished drinking
coffee and I apologize to everybody who
had to hear that at the top of the show
of all places this is as you know the
number one place for news viral hits and
weekly gas if you want to know what's
going on in the world if you want to
have a couple of laps while you're at it
also viral hits this is the number one
place to come and enjoy those three
things right ela yes well you weren't I
think it's number four gas for weekly
gaffes who else is doing weekly gaps
nobody you know there's that's it guys
keep it up on the iTunes chart smash
that review button because look it's
kind of embarrassing we I know most of
our views are on YouTube and they're
very good I'm very proud and happy with
the but I mean we're we're slacking on
the iTunes charts and it's kind of
embarrassing because if I'm foolish
Maximus if I'm Lord foolish Maximus and
I'm not even in the top 100 chart and I
know nobody even listens on audio maybe
some people it's a very visual podcast
it's more of a show really because we
watch stuff and I'm not very good at
catering to audio well traditionally a
podcast is just audio it's it's
something that you listen so really I
mean I guess it's not really is it yeah
I mean you know let's look up the
definition what is contradictory of
focus on the wall podcast audio why well
here let me learn yes oh here's the
definition a digital audio file made
available on the internet for
downloading to a computer or mobile
device so what we do have a digital
audio file if you are listening but it
but you're really listening to and the
audio of a video this is a video you
know like when you're making a podcast
you're not you're not talking about
yeah I I depend a lot on Vuitton visual
elements when I'm watching I'm not very
I'm not very good at catering to all you
listeners but Navi I really think this
through did way when we started this
podcast no it's really a show but people
know what a podcast is if you go to a
sponsor and you're like we've got a new
show yeah exactly
a show oh it's on television no it's on
the Internet
is it a podcast and we'll think about it
yeah clicking this call back later we
only you know what a pod show a pod show
you know we had a lot of trouble getting
sponsors on this show because a lot of
these agencies that do advertising on
podcasts they only count downloads
streams audio streams I'm like why it's
so crazy because I just had a
conversation with one of our friends oh
really who podcast and their sponsors
only kind of downloads it's [ __ ]
insane they also do a lot of views on
YouTube it's like okay I can do a read
on YouTube it has a visual element you
can see the link and you can click the
link it's in the description and I can
show you things it's way better look
who's gonna go from lit when you're
listening to a podcast you're on you're
I mean you're driving who the [ __ ] is
gonna what am I gonna pull over oh let
me go over to stamps.com
let me pull over no we don't count views
so we didn't work with any of those
agencies somebody recently came to me
they wanted me to promote a new Netflix
special and they're asking me the rate
and I said well here's the rate and he
says okay well we don't count YouTube
views only downloads I was like well
[ __ ] call someone else
you called it you called you know we are
90 percent of our views are if anyone is
crazy someone else and also you may want
to change your rules but
because this is actually 2019 I can't
believe it
it's so strange I guess it's just like
it's a bunch of old people mm-hmm and
they know one thing they know downloads
and they understand how to measure it
and once you talk to them about
something else that's oh it's
overwhelming it's too much like well
actually you can see me on YouTube as
well as hear me and there's a clickable
link yeah no but don't only download
sorry you guys okay well a lot of
podcasters cut out the ads they don't
even put them on YouTube because it's
like what's the point
mm-hmm which is like it's such a
disservice to the sponsor anyway that's
that no I'm so worked up thank you to
the sponsors that actually know what the
[ __ ] going on here kaptara
and door - you'll be getting some visual
aids and lots of song and dances and
even a clickable link in the description
you know it's crazy technology yeah
click a [ __ ] link all right I'm all
worked up you know it's way too early in
the show to be getting this worked up I
know I'm still a pain oh well I've got a
bone to pick with you yeah okay there's
a pic Theodore our child two month old
almost has a shirt this has team a mommy
okay I didn't buy that shirt we got it
as a gift well regardless I'm like what
is this propaganda team mommy you know I
know this is [ __ ] I'm holding it and
holding him I'm taking care of him I
feed him oh and I got a look at this
team mommy t-shirt
Yeah right you be sure I fully put that
on them every time team mommy where's
the team daddy shirt
they don't make team daddy shirts look
ice mommy's yes we're pregnant yes and
delivered the boy mm-hmm so we get we
have credit for like for life you know
it's propaganda
mommy Steve mommy for life that's true
yeah nobody likes dads he likes you
nobody like this morning he smiled at
you I didn't get a smile winning smile
was very cute you just walked into his
vision and smiled that's true he did I
was a beautiful thing he's just starting
to learn how to smile so he's he's he's
gonna smile a couple times a day he's
testing it out so the baby's smile is so
pure it's like and they smile so bright
and so beautifully breath it's
incredible the baby smile it's something
else
at first it was smiling from his sleep
like he kind of when he would fall
asleep it would kind of smile and I
noticed the first times I saw him smile
even though I knew you were sleeping and
not even looking at me I immediately
smiled back it's like I couldn't even
control it because it's just it's so
it's a beautiful thing yeah and all
smile is that it's the first time you
see well first of all your child smiling
at you is just so endearing but and but
it's the first time you see your child
as like a human being in a sense because
for the first two months they are just
it's tough man you survival it's just
survival there's not really bonding
there if you're just taking care of a
crying [ __ ] pissing eating machine
they at first also you really don't know
him so you can tell what he needs or
what he's crying about
I feel like now we kinda can tell the
difference between is different crying
cry because it's tired or because it's
hungry yeah and it takes time to know it
that's another thing that people don't
that's hard to expect or to explain is
that when your baby is born you guys are
strangers yeah if there's not like I
don't know I feel like that this is a
bit of a myth
you have this immediate bond with your
child no because the baby comes out and
you guys are strangers you don't know
each other you just met all so you're
like just your after labor you're after
nine months of pregnancy you're going
through so much and you're like you need
to recover yourself you'll barely
yourself even mmm tired you need to heal
and then you have to take care of this
creature too so it's a lot of things
together it's not really like a perfect
bonding time no not at all yeah it takes
a while before you can start feeling
like you know your child or that you
that even is your child for you know and
so it's like you it's it's surreal to
even be like oh this is my son yeah
because it just feels like you're taking
care of a baby
it's I still don't really feel like it's
just still surreal it's so new to me I'm
starting to think this is my son now you
know but it comes and goes it's like
yeah yeah but when he smiles at me you
see that human side of him starting to
develop the personality that there's a
spark of life you know inside of him
brewing a personality is growing yeah
and he starts to see you and and
acknowledge you as a human being he he
knows you're there and he's smiling at
you so it's like what does it mean to
the smile like what does he what does
him like does he find you funny like
what's funny to him you know he's happy
I know it just makes me think like what
was going on inside his head I think
what happens is well for the firt last
like month he's been like you said when
he falls asleep he starts smiling and
asleep you know when you they say when
you're sleep is when your two most
learning and memorizing so he recognized
he sees us smiling and laughing and so
for whatever reason that's one of the
first thing baby's learned to do is
smile and laugh and so every time he
goes to sleep his little mind is working
on figuring out how to do that
and first couple of times he does it
it's cute but there's actually just
going to the motion yeah but now he's
actually expressing joy yeah that's been
a beautiful thing but it's it's yeah
it's been so wild man just sleepy it's
weird it's all weird it's still all a
blur yeah totally no it's all a blur
because I mean just two months ago we
didn't have a [ __ ] baby and now got a
baby
that moment and the hospital seems like
years ago yeah distant memory what you
keep saying and you're right the whole
pregnancy thing is like nothing because
you fear about you have this big anxiety
about the one you have give birth but
what follows is like I was just not real
Christina P is also my mom and she
started a mommy podcast and that's she
talks a lot about this stuff because
it's like no one talks about it and I
feel like we both felt like everyone
like they don't want to talk about it
and there's like when I went to see the
doctor for a check-up afterwards they
were like oh yeah this is the fourth
trimester
this is the real hard [ __ ] and I was
thinking like why all of a sudden I'm
hearing it when I'm going for a
follow-up no one ever talked to me about
what happens after the birth like that
is the real that's when I chosen for ya
but the morning sick everyone in
epidural and all this [ __ ] that's easy
everyone was focusing so much about like
am I prepared for delivery what are my
plans for the way I go to course it's so
stupid
it just it happens you've got alien-dog
you know so you just you can't really
plan so much because at the end of the
day whatever happens happens and you
gotta go with it exactly know you have
no control it just happened yeah you
have to just go with it at the end of
the day but you know what's a real
challenge when you've got a baby that's
been crying for 20 hours straight
screaming you know idea wants to do
screaming in your [ __ ] face and you
are losing your mind
that's the real [ __ ] there's been a
couple of times where I've just been
like I'm holding Theodore he is crying
he screaming you know the first couple
of nights were just and and I'm like I'm
so frustrated because I'm like I don't
know how to help you yeah and you want
to help you you start to feel like a
failure because you're the parent and
you can't even help him you don't even
know why he's growing or what to do yeah
and also on top of everything you're
both of us don't even have time to be
ourselves or to pay attention to each
other like and you're not the
relationship is all weird it's like you
don't have time to watch stuff like we
used to or hang out
it's just everyone is in survival mode
right I mean it's getting easier now
because now we we know the baby and well
well holder we're making it through the
tough part I feel like you know yeah
he's almost two months now I think
that's a big day for the first two
months of talking so mental it's it's
bite like the first couple of days are
insane the first week is rough the first
month hard and then it starts to kind of
like I feel like it's just starting to
get easier maybe this week yeah because
well on top of everything you've said
it's just he is very demanding because
he's just crying all the time and he's
very actually and Theodore specifically
he's got to be one of the toughest
babies is colleague which he has gas
issues he spits up all the time he's
gassy so he's uncomfortable and crying
all the time
he's like a farting machine a burping
machine so the gas and the little
tummies and intestines hurts them
because they're so little it's you know
when you have like painful gas so they
feel that all the time and Theodore has
got to be one of the toughest kids
because he is just you would feed him
and he'll eat it up and then he's just a
miserable afterwards because yeah which
is so it's such a bummer because you
feel like you fed him he shouldn't be
happy now and it's it's not like that he
then he starts to have gas and then
he needs to burp so he's crying because
he needs to work then he was spitting up
[ __ ] load it would spit up a lot and
still cry and then we don't know does it
mean that he wants more food now or to
come out no cuz a lot of times we're
like oh he just needed more food we're
like oh yeah we figured out he just when
he cries he wants more food but then not
all not always yeah and the first three
days were like the some of the craziest
ever because he was losing weight he was
he in army and he was a little bit no
but he was losing a lot of weight yeah
like because we took him to the doctor
and then we went for follow-ups every
day but they were tonight it was it kept
losing a losing weight and then my milk
wasn't coming in yeah so we we both wish
that someone told us to just give him
formula earlier well you know what well
there's a lot of myths around formula
there's a lot of we're getting into a
whole other topic I feel like
breastfeeding is a cult and people try
to force you into breastfeeding so the
dollar to mind but I agree with that
because well it took it to the point
where where people didn't even we didn't
even really consider formula as an
alternative when our baby was literally
starving to death he would scream our
vase like newborn babies are supposed to
sleep 18 hours a day he slept like five
hours a day and the rest he was just
right ten out of ten agony and and and
then you know it's true that
breastfeeding does stuff like it helps
with the immune system but there's this
kind of old long-lasting myth that it
like gives you ten IQ oh yeah and I'm
like that doesn't really make sense
and so I'm started looking into it and
it's based on some old kind of not very
sound research studies either way you
can do whatever you can do if your
body's not producing enough milk is
starving yeah in your case there was a
biological issue but still there's a lot
of people that
well at any rate I agree that don't you
just got to do what you got to do but
they kept bringing us to follow up so we
were there every day after delivery like
I was you know we'd like to stay at home
and heal and stay with him but every day
we had to go back there and everyone in
the hospital all they would talk about
his breast feeding let me see your
nipple my nipple looks fine there's no
reason he's latching everything is fine
yeah well okay he's latching he's on me
for two hours and he's still crying yeah
now I know that he was starving yeah
yeah the whole thing was so fresh that I
knew earlier is really upsetting that
after all that time that they had to
wait till like he was actually lost a
concerning amount of weight when they
actually start to get war was when he
didn't pee oh yeah he didn't eat for
like two [ __ ] days and we were there
every day they knew that it wasn't
peeing did we talk about how they were
gonna give him a catheter we did yeah
you did when I wasn't here yeah and you
know it's like hello
of course he's not peeing he's not
[ __ ] drinking anything I don't know
it's annoying and they have these people
there that are like a lactation
specialist yeah I thought these
[ __ ] were doctors they're just
some women yeah they're not doctors dude
just all they did was talk about my
nipples yeah they can't see anything
about it was it was so weird and every
single person that saw Ella's nipples
was like you have beautiful nipples you
ever fake nipples so every single person
and we go to a new person and then they
would look at his nipples and unprompted
without talking to anyone else would be
like Sheila or you have beautiful perf
amiable
are normal it's regular you have
beautiful perfect no listen big ass
[ __ ] like I said handlebars no no but
it's true when you when you got but it
when you gave birth here when I'm
looking back at it I get annoyed yeah
because what is this call it's the
breastfeeding cult it is and it's at the
hospital which makes me really upset
because it's people at the hospital
should worry about the kid not about
breastfeed well and also please start on
door
tell me to give him formula because I
don't know what I'm doing and the doctor
never this was all from these these
consultants you know who are just ladies
they're not even nurses I figured they
were [ __ ] I think they just they
offload this work onto these pseudo
doctors these breasts lactation
specialist because the nurses and
doctors don't have time to talk about
this [ __ ]
and so they undergo some training
courses and that's it and they and you
know we all know that it's preferred but
I mean my god of course I wanted to
anyway I tried he was on me for so long
and like it's exhausting and it's you
got to sit out there with your boob out
for two hours hoping that he's getting
something you did have it's a young life
giving perfect God I mean they look like
this microphone nothing but when you
gave birth because you I mean I agree
your nips are normal there no but when
you gave birth they turn into a couple
handlebars I know it changes yeah I know
guys so they're right you did it perfect
but I never got to suck your tip no
whatever I did I kept thumping for three
weeks or maybe the first month I don't
remember anymore and I gave him whatever
I could
but God give me [ __ ] give me let me
go to some other tip now Theodore felt
no I never tasted tip milk I never but
you saw what was coming out versus what
he was hitting like he was already
eating let's say two hours and I was
good it was like a quarter when he was
born
now he's eating I don't know how much
we've talked enough about breastfeeding
but I don't know how much milk
these women are producing because he is
Chuck white it's crazy amount of milk it
becomes a problem sometimes they're
producing too much and it hurts and they
need to get rid of some filling a whole
damn 2-liter carton get some cereal
right
anyway Theodore's doing great he
undergoing extreme mommy propaganda
which I don't like but I am I am also
team on me so I didn't buy that shirt I
wouldn't I believe in me mom is a team
why don't you just get a shirt this is
[ __ ] dad when he gets kid shows his
dad's suck you want to watch them Ethan
Bradberry stuff of course okay so you
guys know that Ethan Bradberry is bent
on the regula the regulation for
Megillah and I've been digging into his
Instagram page and he's got this whole
godfather persona words like you've been
good to your mother I haven't got a call
from your mother in three months which
sounds bad but it's good cuz apparently
all the moms call Ethan Bradberry when
they have complaints about their kids or
whatever reasons never heard of such a
thing
and I've long speculated that whatever
whatever there was Ethan Bradbury's
personality he's been completely
possessed by this man and he walks
around in life and this is how he talks
to everybody I don't think he knows how
to function outside of this Papa Bear I
mean like the grant the but you know the
girl the god problem the god very so
here I mean I've pulled a lot of samples
from his Instagram growing all the way
back what's the date on this one to 14
weeks ago February 14th and I think he's
only gotten deeper and deeper into this
is been on it for a while a long time so
let's start we're gonna start recent and
go back or do you want to start you want
to start back in time up yeah okay so
this is the first known instance of the
god Papa making an appearance this was
in East Village Manhattan 14 weeks ago
oh we don't have sound yeah the site's
probably still need mother of God
okay what we got going on the lair we
get in what are you out of your minds
great to see you getting Bradbury where
you've been brother tell you in a second
come over bring it in baby the kisses
are really interested but the mother's
been calling me to your mother capisce
so this has been going on since February
yeah homeys don't even know he's like oh
that's good news my mom caught it not
good look at homee in the background
haha Annika your mother's been calling
that's the first known instance that's a
true artist he's leaving is a heart you
know that's true it's like have you seen
the movie The Prestige yeah what the
twins I'm gonna I do think I just
spoiled it I spoiled all movie well it's
but the point is that at room is it Muse
magician a true artist it's not about
what happens on stage it's about the
whole life is the trick he was doing
tricks that nobody knew how and the
twist was he had a twin brother there
was two of them and their whole lives
was dedicated to convincing the world
there was only one of them that's Ethan
Bradberry that's the dedication that's
required here you go
the second known instance now hold the
[ __ ] phone this is why does this say
23 weeks ago to comment yeah but but why
this is from 23 weeks ago this one's
even older hmm February 15th wait
they're both from February I don't know
what was the day
yeah yeah yeah
[Music]
[Music]
okay the reference and move your it has
to be yeah I don't know which one you
know I feel like our viewers could well
their own lines loose yeah I mean if you
guys know what's going on I'm sure it's
from a movie or something but no sorry
but this one's great because like Bruno
is always down to ride with them this
guy doesn't know what's going on and as
far as I can tell he's at a Funeral
cuz he says condolences to your cousin
like what and he and homeys not down at
all he gets really aired
you'll see here good hey I'll check it
out I got a hairy approaching me going
on over here baby
will you get in yeah Oh was it seemed
like you come over here I got son to
tell you my condolences go out to your
cousin huh
all right listen that doesn't eliminate
the fact your mother keep calling Mike
listen he's holding is facing the keys
good to your mother a few months ago you
was good too
what's changing
approaching what do you think and don't
know so yeah Frankie was holding his
face he was holding him prisoner he's
really had a good strong hold on his
face and his home he had to break away
Ethan Bradberry pulls it off like get
out of here
you're right Bruno he's right or die
yeah Bruno gets into it by does continue
cuz I mean my goodness there's a whole
slew of these here Bruno's back you know
it's gonna be good
when Bruno's in it dude brings right oh
[ __ ] like he'll take this meme all the
way she says she want to be part of the
animal kingdom on a high off easy
yeah man okay man that's what she's
gonna get on you gonna give it a get a
bar a mop I got a box
I ain't gettin it oh he's going in for
the kill only I I think Bruno needs to
know his place though I was
uncomfortable to anyone in to kiss the
papa bear cuz you know who are you
passionate kissing so there's one
specific clip where the kissing gets so
passionate it's here with Bruno of
course the kissing gets so passionate
that I'm certain they're just gonna
start making out where you're looking
oh man they're an inch away look how
dude they are literally about to make
guy because that is a passionate gave me
the first phone call in six months
gaming look how they're gonna make that
up to the church she's coming along with
us to the church
to the town
yeah so weird just imagine these guys
like established their own society like
what would happen of a society where
Ethan Bradberry was that it's their
language the language of noises it'd be
this new guy yeah man
Bruno's such a legend we got one more
year huh whoo you can't forget about it
oh yeah this one get is very intimate as
well one day ago Andy Jo Gambino reach
into the front of me and heart of
Brooklyn New York City you be good to
your mother I mean great to my mother
that's good keep it that way she hasn't
given me a call in about two months
the janitor
spades in far-off drink Araya he gets
angry because it's not raw it's not i
see the cream and sugar come on that's
amore a mother the great dear mother
everybody's on Conrad Bruno Bruno he's
ready to [ __ ] one night they'll have one
drink I feel like Bruno actually might
be into it but he's too afraid to get in
touch with that side of himself and he
doesn't know if Ethan is being serious
or it's meme but I do feel like there
could be a romantic connection there
yeah right
I'll keep following dude I'm just
waiting for them to be like Bruno and
they start making out the tongues and
[ __ ] what we got here huh all right well
it's break time right then start to take
a break when we come back we were going
to have in has prepared a PowerPoint for
us the Bank on little nas X is rise to
stardom and smashing the world record of
the longest-running song at number one
on a hundred billboard so there's a lot
of intrigue and a lot to get to right
after this quick commercial break
ela do you ever have trouble finding the
perfect software yes you could look
online and everywhere for hours and
hours and days and days because you have
a very specific problem and you need the
perfect software that's gonna address
that problem do you know what I'm saying
cap Tara that's why cap Tara is so
genius because they aggregate software
from niche stuff as much as yoga
management systems yoga studio
management systems all the way up to
something as accessible as you know
accounting software content management
software whatever your problem is in
business you need a solution cap Tara
has got the perfect software to address
that issue and not only that II look it
gets better
they've got users with their well let me
just put it this way nine hundred and
fifty thousand reviews of products from
real software users okay reviews are big
online these are real people real
reviews because you can find the perfect
software but for all you know might just
be malware okay but here you get to read
actual reviews you get to see how people
enjoyed it this cap Tara is a
one-of-a-kind place on the internet
you've got all the software aggregated
for your businesses you got nearly a
million reviews of real users using this
product there's nothing else like it
okay join the millions of people who use
cap tear each month to find the right
tools for your business needs and I want
you guys to be successful I want your
businesses to grow and with kaptara
you're gonna be able to do that finally
so visit cap Tara calm / h3 it's free
baby to day right now find the tools to
make an informed software decision for
your business cap Tara calm /h Street
that's kaptara
CA p ter ra comm / h3
are you hungry right now well let me put
it this way do you want $5 free towards
your next meal cuz that's what doordash
is offering you right freaking now let
me tell you about doordash their
delivery service they got hooked up with
all the bomb major restaurants in your
neighborhood they got 3,300 cities in
all 50 states and canada as well
it's door-to-door delivery amazing
restaurants everything you love they've
got you know for anything from Chipotle
Wendy's chick-fil-a Cheesecake Factory
and any of your favorite restaurants
around they've got it all connected and
here's their offer that is so out of
control right now you get five bucks
that's it free five bucks off an order
of $15 or more when you download the
door - app and enter promo code h3 boom
right there just give it a shot that's
five dollars off your first order when
you download the door - app from the App
Store and enter promo code h3 easy as
that promo code h3 five dollars off your
first order from door - guys it's that
simple you're hungry I'm hungry let's
order some bomb-ass food give it a shot
you get five dollars for free it's
really that simple you know I think
there's really nothing more to say
welcome back
it's time finally for in the in turn
PowerPoint we've missed it dearly it's
been way too long and get that sweet
little why you goin in the kitchen I'm
summoning you and he's walking in the
kitchen you're being summoned in the
intern god bless it where's the song we
got in here you know applause he's
dressed for the occasion let's what are
you wearing here today let's see your
shoes he's got his Wow suede shoes are I
mean nice way not suede these are just
really just dress shoes I'm sure there's
no Gucci loafers I'll tell you that
and other non slides no they're not I'm
just wanting van today
all right so but the cowboy hat looks
good and I appreciate you getting in the
character yeah you know it's cowboy time
you guys got some too so yeah I thought
you were gonna bring up movies there's
other right there okay saddle up little
Dallas cheerleader yeah I like the blue
and red you look American as [ __ ] I'm
okay anyway so would you like to have a
seat chair swapping yes what okay swap
shop we're picking it up house it as the
energy over on that side of things um
it's fine this HD podcast is very it's
powerful statement know where you are
but I only just found out that this
isn't a punch I know it's not really is
it not really yeah well that's a bit of
a but we're gonna call you late it's our
bleep you wrote it on the wall kind of a
twist all right so I have a little video
[Music]
and justice green there this is royalty
free music I trust you know you're doing
tip the beanie to you so are you gonna
explain who's little knows X do they I'm
not really sure what I was about to
happen um should I just follow your lead
stay is there any questions I should be
asked so we give any background go ahead
guys you got it so we'll play the clip
okay and then we'll we'll dive in I can
take the wheel jesus take the wheel
always Dan is that all good can you good
yes yeah you're all good okay
this prepares this 800 that was so fast
you're not gonna read it I mean I could
really work you know Pete this is a
podcast people are listening but why do
I see there are two levels it's not what
people actually see no no okay because
it was covering okay can we restart
reboot no but there are people listening
so someone's got to read that I mean but
also I'm not like I'm not Goodwill
Hunting I can't that was so fast I
didn't get a chance to read it do you
want me to do I want you to go back
first of all okay
somebody's got to read it I think you
I'll read it you're at the helm yeah all
right all right
July 29th Old Town Road officially broke
the record for longest number one on the
Billboard Hot 100 I know but you
couldn't even read it faster I could
read that fast enough July 29th Old Town
Road officially broke the record for
longest number one song on the Hot
Billboard Hot 100 and congrats to
robust
thank you oh no way no that's it were
the noise of thunder one of the four
beasts saying come and see white horse
[Music]
holy [ __ ] that was the very green right
I'm going to take my horse do the Old
Town Road ride until I can't no more I'm
going to take my horse to the old town
road right until I can't no more I'm
going to take my force do the Old Town
Road right until I can't know until I
can't no more woah thank you I gotta
watch it I want to watch that again I
don't want it I'm not gonna make
everyone do that but that was
spectacular I'm going to the Old Town
Road I love how the NAS broke into the
pentagram or the triangle yeah you know
there's a lot of layers to this this
goes for me I don't know if I can I
thought I knew what I was doing and what
I was talking about not really but okay
we'll get there great so well do the old
school PowerPoint yadda yadda
I really like that edit in really good
thank you thank you yeah it uh it turned
out so this is the ballot of little pony
lad the tenth wait whose pony Lud little
Moss X I just think Pony lad I like the
pony because you have a picture of
actual NAS and so no it's not and I did
draw that horse to I think it looks
pretty good
thank you yeah yeah
so we're gonna run it back to kind of
the origin of whatever he's doing the
country music rap hip hop fusion thing
these are kind of like a wild these are
the these are kind of precursors you
know these are the the guys who laid the
paths kool Moe Dee Bone Thugs and
harmony Outkast
rock UGK Bubba Sparxxx Timbaland Will
Smith Nelly Tim McGraw young Carl Nappy
Roots young thug family don't matter
these are freaking these are the guys he
comes from a long line of he stands on
the shoulder of giants in other words
yes but these people all took themselves
very seriously so I think that's the
they were actually trying to blend these
two genres like in a very smooth right
but self-serious way a lot of like
bravado and all that type of thing right
outlaw cowboy vibes I think though
little nose is a bit more similar to
this guy meme hey cough yeah see you
showed a picture of Weird Al yes lil
mouse reminds me more of weird Oh
interesting
he's like what Weird Al did with white
and nerdy he's like the reverse hi
that's how I see it I think you're right
he doesn't take himself seriously which
is kind of the power yeah I mean the
whole video it's based on like red damn
Redemption mm-hmm yeah he just likes
that video yeah he has no like roots in
the stuff like the I just it's like a
meme you know like the game and then
jumped on so last year this song came
out by this guy fly rich double called
you up on my tractor I can play like a
little snippet of it right play it we're
gonna we're gonna have to dispute all
day here but yeah go ahead and play it
[Music]
Oh farm and there's a whole bunch of
homies [ __ ] around on a tractor pretty
awesome yeah yeah so this was a last
year in August the resurgence yeah this
was kind of the transitioning it into
more of like a joke like these guys are
kind of joking you can tell the vibes a
little differently so little backstory I
did reach out to little nos a while ago
to interview him because I wanted to do
a PowerPoint uh back when he started
gaining this like traction and then he
just goes to me what you were in touch
before I blew out before so Wow I
emailed him on April 2nd 2019 and then I
followed up again the next day
hi again and there's more to the email
and you know laying out our numbers and
I told him I only want to talk for like
just five minutes on the phone that's
like all I wanted first of all let me
say I did not know about this in and I
love the yeah I love the go getting that
I'm seeing here well now I hold a grudge
against this man he just left me on red
he blew up because then I emailed him
April 3rd April 5th the billy-ray remix
came out so then it was all big shot
yeah it was all turbo racer he left your
ass on the old town oh yeah he did wait
did he ever respond to you because I
don't know he never answered oh well why
do you hold it grouch I thought you guys
had communication just because it goes
to him he just he didn't even he just
click the checkmark and click mark is
read without opening it yeah I don't I
think you're left on red I left your
left on red I'm just in the email yeah
yeah dude that's even worse my grudge is
even stronger than
hmm so having said that you know I think
that uh he's a thief and a liar and a
cheat like No
so why would you how could you say that
well there's this other song we talked
about this now let me ask you this
before what was the point of playing the
previous song well those two that song
came out still before long Moss's but I
want I think that was inspired as well
by this next song this song came before
everything yeah okay so this song
actually came out on May 8th and then
the remix eleven days later so with a
little izzy vert who we're all familiar
with my favorite rapping Satanist
absolutely so he jumped on this the and
this came out old town road came out in
December of last year so a short five
months later yeah or something yeah so I
think months this is kind of like the
inspiration behind these songs
[Music]
really not very clear like let me know
the chorus I got horses into my car and
then there's also other lines he says
I'm sipping lean like a Coors Light and
Louis you know lied about personally
this has been stuck in my head more than
all those maps for you yeah I really
can't get out of my head so what these
two songs came first you're saying so
this came out in May so this guy kind of
set the resurgence of the cowboy hip-hop
chic back into brought him back into the
forefront of our cultural consciousness
really am i right yeah so well both of
them cite this other guy young thug who
did a song but it's not a jokey song
well let me hear that one I don't have
it oh okay lights cut can we cut that
Dan can we cut that why not but that was
not as much of a joke as this this is
clearly like this is him just joking yes
it's putting on the accent and goofing
around
yes so I think lil knows pretty much
directly he definitely heard this I've
no doubt and then made his song
and then certainly I just the lines are
similar I don't know I know knows how
much he was inspired by well I mean I
I'm sure you're getting to it it seems
didn't little NAS reach out to this dude
for a collab yes so that's the next last
and that proof that he's hurt because
you said I'm pretty sure he's heard of
it isn't that not proof yeah yeah yeah
yeah definitely
okay so well this is the guy little
Tracy little Tracy who made that song
there he is saying I was actually
inspired by young thug to make like a
farmer Lowell nos simply ran with the
sauce
well no sex is not innovative he is a
fake mogul okay well let me address
actually I feel like go ahead and on the
screen on the note this is all so these
are all deleted tweets now but this is a
DM oh he tweeted it yeah Wow and then
deleted it so this is a little Tracy
saying Lowell nos deemed him on January
1 a hop-on Old Town Road so that's like
just a couple weeks after it came out he
put it out and then immediately reached
out to a little Tracy hang on
Oh Zoe so you damned him and then he
tweeted it out cuz he said broad why did
you tweet that I've been trying this
song so that actually he's responding to
Lowell nos tweeting I think the one on
the left yeah like why are you attacking
me I tried to get you on this song so so
hold on he said you want to hop on the
song he said yes but he said it well two
months later and oh and this guy wants
to get on only after he blew up well
that what I'm seeing here I think maybe
we're releasing the dance on the right
little Tracy he tweeted this because I
don't know if he's exposing himself
because on the left when did what sound
Road come out December at when was the
suite on the left tweeted cuz the date
is cropped out the one on the left
it was around I'm pretty sure around
March
okay so little nod says you want to hop
on Old Town Road mm-hmm and then whoa
and then two months later and then a
month later he tweets out [ __ ] lo nas he
copied my sauce yeah and then a month
later again he responds and says yes
around the same time this yeah I think
it's around the same so he's he doesn't
actually want he just [ __ ] he may
just being a there goes little nas is a
[ __ ] he goes into the dmz says he yes
and then little nose has brought why'd
you tweet that I've been trying to get
you on this song and then he says get me
on it yeah
he's just being a dick I think so now
let's address the themes free so and
then people were saying at his live
concerts he said like [ __ ] holy [ __ ] Old
Town Road
so he's cut out let me address this guy
Tracy vert Ethan real quick can you sit
up all the way yeah I got lean on my
bladder dude come on he says I was
actually inspired by a young thunk to
make like a farmer okay first of all
Tracy Burt
you yourself are saying that you're not
an original you met you were inspired
yeah okay so what the [ __ ] is your point
you in your original tweet say that
you're inspired by a young thug young
thug gonna go accuse him of ripping him
off so he feels like he was inspired
versus little nasty thing actually
copied him but I feel like you're
walking such a gray area here like I
don't see listening to both of the songs
I don't see it as a coffee well he says
he stole his sauce actually no he
doesn't even say that he says ran with
the sauce you know maybe there was some
sauce that he ran with it but I have to
say after hearing both songs the son I
mean they're very different and let me
also say that what little nas made with
Billy Ray Cyrus is a hit yeah that song
is there dude it's like crazy I mean
this guy's song is just a little
soundcloud [ __ ] post right I that song
never had the potential to go number one
billboard No
okay so he did he take though so he says
he took the sauce and he ran with it
that's exactly what he did and I've seen
a lot of comments people saying Tracy
vert walked so lil nos could run and
that's exactly right that's what
happened yeah not a bad thing no it's
not a bad thing I don't either
I totally and for him to say not
innovative he's a fake mogul I mean well
I don't think he's ever purported to be
a mogul just a dude that made a hit the
things that sometimes does just there's
trends in the air you know people feel
the same vibe and people get inspired
from each other and people end up making
sometimes similar things and it doesn't
mean they copied each other
absolutely I see it a lot with teddy
fresh people will point out auto color
blocking and they'll be like they're
copying you so you know they're not then
they're totally not
I quit first of all I didn't invent
color blocking not even close and second
of all it's just a trend right now and a
lot of people are feeling it you are
liking it they're gonna wear it right
now they're running with the sauce yeah
right
and it's possible they saw her
color-block and they saw how popular it
is but that's okay I mean I'm not a copy
no and I mean in the marketplace of
ideas you just got to have a better idea
you and I think lil nas made a better
product ultimately it was more
successful for this guy to have a chip
on the shoulder I mean he could have
here the opportunity to get on that [ __ ]
he really he [ __ ] himself over by not
getting on that didn't it yes so the two
remixes go 3:45 I don't remember well
young thug jumped on the guy oh that's
beautiful he's on the one with Mason
Ramsey though so by the way we were
discussing this and I was like Ian how
how is it that all these remixes are
coming out and he still has one song at
number one and you answer me mm-hmm
yeah they all funnel to billboard takes
the most successful one all the remixes
that come on after that all of the you
know momentum and streams and so it all
funnels into the main one so so little
nas you have to respect the Huff so this
little Cowboys got because these remixes
dude this guy is hustling for that
number one spot and you also have to
appreciate he tweeted out he says he
made the song specifically two minutes
long so people could stream it more yeah
yeah it's 30 seconds to to count as a
stream mmm so yeah the last remix was
like 150 homie just keeps cutting down
though yeah but you got to appreciate
the hustle man this guy's making he just
released a remix with some k-pop guy
that people were losing their minds
about sounds the [ __ ] same it's just
blamed because he's trying to tap into
that market it's all like just market
it is so I thought I follow him and like
everything he posed he looks so happy
though he's always goofing around and
had like I'm up he's so like silly and
just enjoying the ride he's got a great
vibe I feel like it's a shame because um
Tracy Tracy Vartan how should I lose
little Tracy little Tracy he made such a
silly song and then he goes on and being
so petty if your vibe is like this
silliness you should let it go and join
join the part when the [ __ ] rodeo
instead of Kilda party joined the party
joined the rodeo dude it's a goddamn
powwow let's do a dosey doe you know
what I'm saying in I know I know we'll
we'll ring around the hay bales
something like that but anyways yeah so
I do feel kind of but I do like his song
and it's but I like his song a lot yeah
I mean I get why maybe he's upset but it
sucks that you know I don't I don't I
don't he needs to get over it yeah in
this world you you don't get anywhere by
by getting yeah and making enemies you
gotta join you got to bring the [ __ ]
cornbread you got to join the dosey doe
you got to get yourself a partner and do
the goddamned OC dope I don't feel bad
for him also what you always will learn
is that there was room for everyone yes
you're easy
he's not stealing lessons from yours
unless you're on twitch twitch is the
only place there's not right yes there's
face in this world for everyone yeah you
know yeah and I feel like as well he did
get apparently at one point lil nos had
a playlist on soundcloud he it's deleted
now and it was songs that pave the way
to Old Town Road and like a farmer was
on there so that was him kind of going
like you did I did take from this but
you know here's me promoting it yeah
well you can easily make the argument
that the references to lean and horses
in the back are also nods to this song I
mean he can give the nod to the song and
he's not state a little homage yeah
exactly it's not that sure yeah I mean
the SOT the song sound completely
different oh this is so all the flip and
remixes I'm really going all in with
these graphic
here I love uh so there's the first one
with Billy Billy Ray Cyrus then he did
one with Diplo then one with young thug
in Mason Ramsey there's a leaked one
with Lil Wayne no way really even out
yet it's not out you can find it you can
find it is it fire I haven't heard it is
it sound the same as all the I don't
partake in the legal content only you're
just telling people it's out there yeah
I've never heard it though never heard
it then that guy are his name's RM from
BTS which is a k-pop group that everyone
goes nuts over and then apparently
there's a possible one up coming with
this rapper Megan the stallion and Dolly
Parton
so Dolly Parton's been tweeting about it
who wait what what who's a Dolly Parton
singer country singer hasn't she doesn't
she like I don't know is she alive I
mean if she's not that's a big feat for
him Dolly Parton isn't she from like
1920 my crazy Dolly
how old is Dolly Parton Dan she's like
she's not from the 20 she she is she
real but yeah yeah if I had to guess
she's probably in her 70s right because
she was like one with the tumbleweed by
now she's 73 hazard okay well let's get
the Dolly Parton on the gravy hot yeah
that's fire I love that he's dipping
into all the country yeah icons you know
he's dipping everywhere and I'm I'm
ready for it to be over well you got
your cowboy hat on and you're in your
suede shoes you don't look like you're
I'm hoping that it's so corny it skill
helping to kill the meme I don't think I
think this i think this i think this
meme is it just started the gallop
that's on to a full-blown that's
nightmare I'm starting to see the end of
it sighing we we've been fans of the
song we listen to it a lot
well they all just sound the same right
yeah I heard them walk BTS everyone's
freaking out about I was like oh it
sounds exactly the same it sounds it's
the sounds even worse yeah I kind of
agree
but I'm in oh wow was that real wow she
looks really good Mike yeah she's
looking pretty skinny oh good
the record for longest number one is now
17 weeks as of yesterday breaking the
16-week tie between 2017 Luis FONSI
daddy yankee Justin Bieber audio or g'd
Esposito and the 1995 Mariah Carey boys
2 men
dusts one sweet day so at its crazy
those two songs were we're holding the
record one sweet day what the f is that
that was kind of before my time so I
don't I don't know I'd never heard it
until I looked this up I can't believe
how good Mariah Carey looks though she's
been taking care of herself
yeah yeah she's really looking trim so
yeah and then we've got so here are all
the people that have tried to take him
down tried and failed
tip number one goes and they have not
overtaken lil mouse X on billboards okay
yeah released singles yeah they were
they were going for it they were yeah
yeah yeah so we got Bugatti Biebs
we got the ginger fury we got Onika
minaj we got language are you speaking
we got a post tmaloney be god dude I'm
surprised that even post wasn't able to
cuz every time that got released the
song it's like hey I'm number one what
song did he release it was goodbyes with
young thug young thug making a different
order making an appearance but no yeah
we got a Kathryn B we got T Swizz this
is everybody
we got Shauna --then Mendes we got Billy
the Kid that's everybody we got freaking
Aubrey that's everybody
Aubrey champagne papi Drizzy six-gun
what the wheelchair Graham the legend
and the burger lady too
that's everybody they all tried and
failed they even tried to mix and match
Billy they tried to get Bugatti Bebe's
on the remix to her song to try and bump
it up and Ed Sheeran worked with Bieber
to try and tag team none of them can do
it the power wasn't that Bieber Twitter
Congrats and that's all he said
just congrats almost through a couple
more letters or congratulations it's a
yeah right that's what I thought
congratulations it's like wow dude with
no exclamation mark I think I think
there was nothing yeah man that's a
weird that's very cryptic in a way yeah
because Justin Bieber is like that's not
that's literally not cryptic I said
congratulations is it so that's mostly
all the main power players I mean who
are we sides ariana grande has a single
coming in like a week or two but that's
so she's away and then she'll be right
up here with all these losers it's too
late and uh and then I del Adele's the
only woman I think could do it she's
gone she's missing but it's too late he
already won like they they faced they
swung and they missed they all aimed for
the head they'd do anything for that
yeah aim higher next time
yeah they blew it so these people are
all failures or do you have a they gonna
I want to see them like just dump away
like a dust effect yeah yeah we can add
that in later oh man no spinners just
gone these are the longest running
number ones ever this is just kind of an
interesting list look at him
there's a lot of [ __ ] on this loose dog
handling the wind something about the
way you look tonight I'm actually
unfamiliar with that song but I
obviously can't on the wind yeah there's
a lot you know what it is it's like
these are all radio hits
I'll just read read some of these so
that we got the Macarena 14 weeks that's
insane imagine a world go back what year
was that from
1996 imagine a world where Macarena is
actually I don't need to imagine I
remember number one for 14 weeks hey
Macarena daga daga beretta hey that was
insane before listening to that everyone
was doing the dance at every bar party
even in Israel yeah it was we got I got
a feeling the Black Eyed Peas
I've got out to will uptown funk Bruno
Mars we got Eminem lose yourself yeah uh
sure in Little John
boom boom pow Black Eyed Peas blurred
lines was Khalifa see you again the
chainsmokers closer that's like one of
the worst songs I've ever heard whoa
hang on what are we doing I'm talking
[ __ ] I'm straight not fired I hate that
song huh ed sheeran shape of you what
other songs do hate up here in obviously
we've got the legend Drake champagne
papi six god king drusy slime with god's
plan down there what about the what you
didn't mention the wheelchair wheelchair
Jimmy yeah yeah he's there Olivia
newton-john let's get physical there's
some interesting stuff your boy yeah
easy never made it huh no he's a failure
oh dude he blew it I only count the
numbers he's not here Macarena did woman
part 1 part 2 doesn't look like it part
2 wasn't it wasn't as good as the
original yeah so yeah some interesting
stuff I think I could see him going for
a few more weeks though and really like
solidifying that he's not going anywhere
man I mean that was a long-standing
Mariah Carey had that from 95 well if he
can just get one more week I mean if he
could get to 20 weeks that's a title
that may not ever be toppled until I
release another diss track mm-hmm I
wonder I should have looked it up but I
doubt it if
I carry did any like remake trickery
yeah let's be honest the remixes he's
like could be a little asterisk up there
yeah the remixes such a did any of this
other people though I mean I'm sure some
of these have it but I don't I don't
think to this day I don't think Elton
John has any remix you know yeah I don't
know what about like Drake with God's
plan no or like Eminem would lose
yourself know a lot of the like uptown
funk I don't think has a remix
what about despedido that one hadn't
remixes didn't it so let's see that's
the that's featuring Justin Bieber
that's one up there that was the remix I
also noticed if I can point out Macarena
says Bayside boys mix so that appears to
have been remixed as well
yeah but they listen to remix they
really yeah but I would I do think the
candle in the wind was remixed several
times as well does that yeah I think
that sounds right it was a Dougie fresh
and out and John original beatbox I
think I remember that in the movie that
deleted scene like up let's move moving
on yeah I think there's just crap crap
and mega crap all over this list to be
honest nice so how did he do it I was
gonna try and tie and like he sold his
soul with the devil
so here's the cover with with young thug
and Mason Ramsey for that remix and I
found an interesting tweet that I think
is some truth from from David over here
where he says the devil is cunning look
at this cover tell me what y'all get
from this if y'all that don't understand
the devil works in exoteric and esoteric
medicine so Tara asked Dan he knows
oh I don't know when I saw that I was
like what the [ __ ] is that concise e he
says exoteric and esoteric though yeah
in balls can someone look up exoteric is
that a word yeah I mean I just thought
it was a typo but I guess
yeah exoteric li hey carnal mind can
understand this is just being a cover
about horses cuz oh yeah old town route
but exoteric intended for or likely to
be understood by the general public so
it's like the opposite of esoteric it
can't be both then devil magic as
Christians are told to look past that
which is physical and see what's really
going on read the book of Revelation
you've heard of the four horsemen that's
true I have we're going to have to break
this down because I want you all to know
the nonsense going on he's got a good
amount of read to it some like some
retweets and the devil is cunning yeah
he's here I'm starting to buy it
let's go man I like this homework
he breaks I wish I could get him on the
phone but revelation 6 details four
horsemen their meaning and their color
the first was the white horse a
conqueror well the second is the red
horse represents war the third is the
black horse which represents famine the
last one the green horse represents
death whoa wait what is it green wait
hold on back up oh yeah what why does
green represent death it shouldn't green
represent famine or like you know slime
Organic but you said green represents it
went last death black is very green why
would know this guy's got it all wrong
green should be famine and black is dead
eat green food and it's done to green
there's nothing old death about green I
gotta put my foot down there is this
from the Bible yes years what was that
yes that is correct
he's from the back I'm gonna take this
guy did his homework I'm gonna he did he
knows is great yeah so can y'all explain
to me why the four horses
match the color and the horses in
Revelation why is the white horse the
smallest of the four who is also
representative of Jesus my hurry wait
the full I thought white was part of the
Apocalypse the first was the great white
horse a conqueror Jesus Jesus is also
depicted but there's only four horses so
we're missing a horse Jesus returns on
the Great White Horse in Revelation have
you got the white and what else we got
horses so you got others to brown in the
green yeah
but Jesus white is Jesus so he's saying
by making the Jesus horse all tiny like
that is like spitting in Jesus's face a
fine I'm on board okay it's Four
Horsemen of the Apocalypse
the white is Jesus mm-hmm there's a
brown black we're missing a horse the
white wine Jesus's horse we only have
three riders of the public but this is
like the apocalypse megazord that come
those four right there I think if I
understood correctly Jesus rides the
white horse he isn't actually the white
horse so you got the four horses the
white one being it's his personal horse
that's his ride
yeah but till we get the Bible out do we
have on the back wait hold on I
understand but there's Four Horsemen of
the Apocalypse yes and there's four
horsemen if one of those horses is Jesus
I'm assuming Jesus isn't one of the
Horsemen of the Apocalypse
yes according to this wait what what
Jesus is one of the Horsemen of the
Apocalypse
well that's blasphemy can we just that
would be surprising Jesus like hey I'm
here to end it all look whoa Jesus well
the apocalypse is the second coming
so I mean he'd have to he's involved in
some capacity minute Ian you need to
clarify for us here what's going on
because I know Jesus died before dumb
that's not right the four horsemen are
from de marsay they write for Satan and
it's a war between good and evil that's
revelation okay so here's from Wikipedia
okay thank you in tho theologians and
popular culture differ on the
first horsemen the four riders are often
seen symbolizing conquest or pestilence
and less frequently the Christ or the
Antichrist followed by war famine and
death so it sounds like this is a
controversial topic on the on the white
horse open for interpretation yes Bobby
shocked his health Jesus wrote out with
them be like dude you were [ __ ] a
double agent the whole time well or the
Antichrist so maybe it's you know there
should be a big crowbar separation
between Christ and the Antichrist it's
they got it it's not going pony back
little poney little poney back little
pony lad goddamn this is complicated
well it's a little bit it's like the end
of The Sopranos you know like you they
want to leave it up to the people okay
so then again he's saying the artists
and labels that pump out mainstream
music into the world are not governed by
God they are governed by the god of this
world the Prince of the power of the air
Satan he's blamele mocking Jesus yet we
eat up his music 17 weeks number one I
think people are just they know they
know what's up and then Mason Ramsey
tweets this Getty out our way a photo of
the four horsemen whoa Mason Mason comes
in and that's a photograph it's pretty
cool okay well hold on let me okay so
yeah though there is a white horse a
Bowman I love that the screenshot
captured exactly when the likes go up
yes there's activity going on also liked
by little nods I can see that's him nope
yeah he elect one of my tweets recently
he did yeah that going he said he was on
the toilet and he's you know going
number two while getting number one you
liked it oh that's a good one
David jumped in on this receipt here's
one of your own bearing witness to the
words I've spoken goodnight
the law is not like I know what I
discerned so he's basic
correct he's got the evidence there it
is and also the likes to back it up the
likes are their 8300 Getty out our way
Dan that's what dude what if what if
that's what the horsemen said when they
arrived giddy out our way they did
arrive that's them
lil nas and Lowell giddy that's the
remix the earthquakes are coming back
this all happened during the time of
this song cool so I found one other
video that I think is basically a if
you're not convinced that some devilish
Joker is going on by now this will
confirm it 100%
it's from faithful on YouTube I think
he's got a really compelling argument
here 0 like zero likes two dislikes 113
views I major hit I think that this is a
buried gem I just feel like he's on to
something here so he's just posting some
things he's noticed with lomas that seem
a bit suspicious
he's got a he's got a cross on his beard
he covers one eye he covers one industry
now that's the thing that's very a lot
of devilish trickery in the Hollywood
Hills about we're just touches channel
is this Masonic gesture
go plate the goat and the Sun he's used
the goat emoji which is a symbol of
Baphomet was kind of like The Satanic
figure he's used the Sun emoji as well
this one he didn't really figure out the
in explain down yeah but two out of
three is still compelling that's that's
yeah it's over 50% now he used the okay
sign which is in the shape of a six
which is the devil's number and but he
added so well he kind of added extra
meaning cuz there's only one but then he
added but he couldn't figure out this
screenshot what is it the black bars and
the white yeah it's a little well
because that's irrelevant to the
figuring out the truth which as long as
he demonstrates and [ __ ] X
refers to Antichrist damn you can't even
write in English anytime use an X
referencing that as I'm supposed to skip
that one over no you use this emoji too
at some time at is damning occultic
skulls that's true he's using devil
horns right here that's true
it's all here these are Masonic tiles
he thought he could sneak by us yeah
I've never seen those before like look
right here I've never seen a check of
lousy think we're all blind and not
gonna see this guy's wearing black and
white you know I think every where the
devil horns it's fear he's painting a
picture for us the pentagram stars it's
not an anagram there's only fight there
it is the pentagram oh wait yeah it is
there is evil
he's got the road the road it oh I love
how each out the arrows are arguing
there's a little pentagram star the owl
is the symbol of the Illuminati makers
fun oh that's very illuminating a little
pixel yeah so basically you know it just
keeps going but you get the gist yes
it's damned evidences if you don't
believe it now look it you flipped the
99 in sixes oh my - it's not three
well it's once again
CyberLink by PowerPoint that's it
[Music]
Izzie's a lot to chew on yeah so what do
you think Zia is some suspicious
activity going on some so if you take if
you take everything as a whole yes yes
yeah i covering what's going on with the
years yes what is that you read the
Bible and you have a stroke what are you
saying else like that just please
continue do you have the covering I
mm-hmm concerning these goggle eyes why
cover one right exactly why would you
you've got a jersey that says ninety
nine but when you flip that up sighs it
says 66 it's not there's not three
there's two and you have to flip it
upside down still I'm concerned about
that as well yeah what if you put still
on upside-down wrong way right you've
also got allegations of theft and whole
there's a lot to chew on I'm not sure
the people are gonna have to make up
their own their own minds when this
morning just like is was Jesus on the
horse was he if one of the horsemen in
the apocalypse that was the other
question you're gonna have to make up
your mind on that one as well cuz I'm
not a theology and I mean I couldn't
possibly make a distinction there oh
yeah I don't know but that's it that's
it so hopefully ariana grande please
break the record I don't want to hear
this song ever again I think I'm gonna
be hearing the song many more to come
and I don't think this PowerPoint helped
either because I think people are gonna
go listening so don't do it
we got a default in thank you for coming
out thank you
I was a powerful PowerPoint now we gotta
wait 10 months for the next one
give you kiddy the hell out I got the
horses in the bag as I'm don't you can
leave your hat on Wow
yes they shouldn't I'm gonna leave mine
okay I was interesting learned a lot you
know covered a lot of ground mm-hmm
little nas exposed Dan how long we've
been going for let's see Dan like an
hour 20 so good then we go up for an
hour 20 Wow shall we wrap it pretty
tired again we have so much content to
get to let me do these ones I've got
these old stories I've been putting off
let me just talk about these and then we
can we can get to the rest on Friday
this maybe we should just wrap it up
wrap it up wrap it up but that means
we've only talked about three things
that's how we do it baby that's how we
do it this is not a podcast we're under
no obligation that's true does being a
podcast
give us more obligation or less
obligation what is an obligation
I don't know we have know about of no
let's do this face app craze this is all
[ __ ] new no one even cares yell hurt
you guys remember the face up craze with
the app that made everyone old yes and
then the world actually turns out the
company that made this app is a Russian
company all right so everyone was
getting spooked like what are these
Russians doing with our faces right
first of all before we get into it let
me show you pictures of all of us let me
save this app it's so fantastically good
you look will you love me when I'm I
feel like that's a cute guy yeah that's
pretty cute I'll I'm down to ride like
that what ages that though that's like
79 nice nice yeah I like it
no we skip the next one Oh little
Theodore I got age of five get out of
here with that when I ran it it makes
you select a face so I selected ILA's
but it like spilled over li yeah he got
a little on the forehead I don't know
well at 70 that's pretty good I think
but how is this so good raise yours
looks like a cute old guy I look old as
[ __ ] though you know I mean it's not
flattering if you have hair like that
when you're old that's pretty cool yeah
my hair's gonna look like that cool I'm
pretty sure you didn't get any Gray's
your hair didn't change at all the
changing of the hair color is one of the
most interesting parts to me because
they think it can like detect if you
already have a little bit of gray and
then it enhances it you know it's so
crazy and that's really like I've seen
this person before that's what you're
gonna look like Dan this is a little bit
it looks more like my grandfather
actually this is insane how do you guys
feel seeing this because I feel
horrified when I see myself you know I
get that instinct a little bit but you
got a everybody who [ __ ] gets old
this is something every to be fair Durst
yeah was the least flattering I mean I'm
gonna support is any yeah I think mine's
the worst but no it's not and that's
just bro you look like Gandalf yeah I
mean yours is yours looks yeah I'm gonna
I'm just backing you up and guys I want
you to know I'm supporting HeLa cuz
she's like I look awful right and not
the yeah that's close this
but I mean just you exam we didn't
because we actually know what is that
looks like no they look different yeah
but it's so funny like they recognise
your skin type and they made them all
blotchy I can create it added a little
bit of gray to his hair but for me they
went they went all out right well your
dad your dad has like pure white hair
like what are they scanning my DNA
that's what doesn't know that I love it
fantastic
where's my gray hair maybe you don't
maybe you end up dying it and I knew
that well I know we're dying it I
thought you said dying oh I'm looking
forward to gray hair
so at any rate is this app dangerous
have we fallen prey yet again to Russian
antics the question washington post an
article about it they said some of the
darkest fears of russian connections
research and technical experts said are
overblown the photos are stored on
conventional servers run by american
companies and no evidence has surfaced
said the company has ties to the Russian
government technical analysis has also
found that the app does not as some
rumors stated swipe a person's entire
cache of photos or open their data to
unlimited surveillance yeah
people started to really freak out and
then well I I got a little spooked by it
people said that they saw the app upload
all the photos to the cloud yeah I
worked it all in that yeah that guy
deleted that tweet no he just made it up
concerns arose when people started to
point out that the app seems to upload
all of your photos wouldn't that take
hell of long you don't know the
difference in one photo and all right
and that's when I change phones it takes
like 20 minutes people also discovered
that and the private
see policy page it makes a vague
reference to sharing your data with
affiliates it says quote you grant face
a perpetual irrevocable non-exclusive
royalty-free worldwide fully paid
transferable sub licensable license to
use reproduce modify adapt publish trans
they create derivatives from distribute
publicly perform and display your User
Content and any name user or likeness
provided in connection with your user
contact and all media formats channels
non owned or later developed without
compensation to you that is in this
world or any other be this a simulation
or real all future simulations all all
realities here known as or further
discoverable I'd say that writing is
[ __ ] but apparently it's kind of
boiler right eyes apps
I felt freaked out when I read it and
then people said it's the same one
everywhere like sweet are YouTube that's
the thing you read that language of any
of these apps and you'll realize that
they're like we [ __ ] own you we could
sell a t-shirt with your face on it
I could start towards like I can make h3
March right now and sell it and people
to my rights we use third-party analytic
tools to help us measure traffic and you
should strings for the service these
tools collect information sent by your
device to our service including the
webpages you visit has ODS and other
information that assists us in improving
the service yet truth is that you're
gonna see this language and way worse on
pretty much any app you [ __ ] download
a flashlight app know this whole
migrated to terms thing is that sure I
don't know it's not right it's not right
because there's no way that you're gonna
read it it's I don't know there's no way
that you can not get those apps I mean
you need Twitter and you need all this
stuff today you're kind of choosing to
not be part of society if you're not
participating and all this stuff you
think that's a great point and I think
there's gonna be a point where
we as consumers can say look this
agreement is not binding because you
have to reasonably assume it's
unreasonable to assume that people are
going to read this you're giving common
people without a law background on a
hundred page contract without access to
a lawyer you cannot you have it should
be that if you have terms and services
you can fit on one page and it's in
plain language that's what it should be
you know I mean enough with this what
this law talk is indecipherable to
people without a law degree and we do so
many apps can you imagine reading it for
each one I don't want to know at this
point I don't want to know I don't want
to read it I swear to god I'm not even
kidding I download a flashlight app and
I'm like oh it wants to make calls it
wants to read my contacts it wants to
see my photos it's like it's a [ __ ]
flashlight app I don't want to even know
at this point you can send flashlight
app to see your nude photos and upload
them to revenge porn comm oh wow all
right
agreed yeah I think I think it speaks to
a bigger problem with these apps
that's exactly right ela Wow
should we keep going let's just bring
these out let's bang it out ice cream
challenge you all heard about these
bright-eyed [ __ ] idiots the ice cream
challenge man so this was a challenge
apparently and you guys are gonna love
this
where you going to a grocery store lick
ice cream take the top off you look
diced and you put it back ice cream
again
it's the ice cream challenge this has 13
million views oh look
never licky licky all you filed for
today put it
oh no Billy Leakey all you file put a
bit put a bit 17 I mean yeah you do
unfortunately you do stupid [ __ ] at that
age but dude they posted online and
everyone's like oh yeah
it's been seen by 13 million people
they're like oh yeah I know that girl is
alright you know and I don't know for
some reason this just went huge like
it's disgusting but I think it went
bigger than I would expect
mm-hmm I was immediately wondering how
come it's got no top the ice cream so
magical doesn't have top I mean I guess
I didn't for some reason I thought they
all had like a seal mmm
they've got some advanced techniques
they basically vacuum seal it and so you
can tell if it's been open or not
because the top will be like slightly
popped out apparently still seems stupid
just [ __ ] seal it
like when she put it back do you think
you could tell I don't think so I did
something about that yeah yeah I bet
someone bought that that girl didn't
look clean either well she looked like
any other person but she does herpes
survive in a freezer or well sorry Dan I
mean like hepatitis let's say that's a
more rare disease hepatitis B no one
you're asking if it survives Inside
Edition didn't did a new story about it
I mean this is sort of legs a young
woman is so nasty container of ice cream
and putting it back in the store freezer
linkie oh you found put a bit of it
has been viewed more than 10 million
times
what kind of make it to the news wrote
one person I'm disgusted this should be
a criminal charge posted another Wow the
ice cream in question is blue velvet in
a statement the company said this type
of incident will not be totally gonna do
back could be to a felony charge some
twitter users claimed they've identified
the woman as coming from San Antonio
Texas look at her they got her the
popular brand sold mainly in the South
Inside Edition producer oh yeah that's
my favorite shot as well she's like you
don't believe me here you're walking
down the aisle in a grocery store and
ice cream look at this that shot [ __ ]
made this story Inside Edition you don't
believe me here I am [ __ ] question me
now look at the flavor now this is
investigative journalist hard hit Oh
once you remove the lid and race cream
is exposed Bluebell explains what is
reinvention our half gallons are flipped
upside down and sent to a hardening room
creating a natural seal just cover hoods
are frozen tightly to the carton any
attempt at opening the product should be
noticed noticeable other ice creams do
have a plastic and ice one right there
what the [ __ ] all the sudden I'm
watching some stupid video about ice
cream and then all of a sudden it's a
shooting in Gilroy oh yeah yeah what the
[ __ ] is right YouTube shut the [ __ ] up
if you - oh my god
how to survive a shooting at a festival
that's a video how to survive a shooting
at a festival let's stick to the [ __ ]
ice cream story that's a far cry away
I'm trying to have a good time here
survivors shooting and just like
matching the same woman shooting
tutorial I imagine the same word woman
cruising through in the same outfit
why chill out inside addition total
chaos that's how to survive if you will
enjoy that story you're definitely gonna
enjoy how to survive a shooting [ __ ] you
what is going on with this country there
is now tutorials about how to survive a
shooting reach it sister I thought I
came to the safe America from Israel
mm-hmm and now there's shooting
tutorials here it's actually a hotbed
they put it at the end because people
like oh yeah I do need to know how to
just survive a shooting I'll tell you
how to survive a shooting run that's it
just run right I mean that's not good
upsetting there is no surviving and say
just die you can't do anything what can
you do yeah what is pray I mean you just
you just write to knows like there's a
maniac there's spraying both so I don't
need a [ __ ] youtube tutorial here
here here's the first step pray to God
ask the Lord above to uh
hopefully that you're more righteous
than the people around you
I love to see some preacher like God
will choose God will decide he will know
if you're more righteous he will protect
you if you make a sizeable donation God
will know anyway my intention was not to
talk about this but we were talking
about how so the blue bow company they
said it should be noticeable if someone
opened it that is not enough look the
tops on you're going in your body you're
getting ice cream well though in their
defense why should they have to
anticipate people licking it and putting
it back I mean I don't know it's just
this crazy people crazy okay put a top
on it then yello-ha why is anything
sealed
that you buy I guess cereal why is it
sealed doesn't get still good enough
it's okay I feel like that's good enough
police ended up not charging the girl as
an adult as an adult if I always find it
strange when they charge juveniles as
adults it's like that's the whole point
of the law they're children I'm gonna
try you as an adult you're 16 and now
I'm pissed when I try as adults okay
well he's 16 that's the whole point
sometimes there's a heinous enough crime
but still well at the 16 year old
murders like five people they don't want
to be like well I want you away forever
yeah I get that so of course we have
copycats this is so this girl was 17
this next guy is a grown-ass man and it
has a happy ending too so don't so don't
get too concerned but look at this
winner he looks like he's got kids man
it's like a kid walking by
homey Oh what you really got a [ __ ]
shadow dude you are so dumb
not being a grown man so by the way do
you see the lid I promise you that looks
perfectly new when you put it back on
yeah there's no vacuum in our dan can
you get me some tums I'm experiencing
heartburn I don't know why you got it
mm-hmm
maybe it's the cowboy hat give me in
digestion so this guy looks like he's 40
thank you that's part of me part of me
partner
well I these anti acids I don't miss
having that you know I was having it
especially towards the last month of the
pregnancy oh yeah
you were really suffering by the way
such an awful feeling but this guy's
like 40 and the best part like I said is
happy ending
authorities have located this man
Louisiana after he posted a video of
himself licking ice cream and poking it
and putting it back Martin returned to
Big B's to meet the police he he showed
a receipt alleging he had purchased the
ice cream he said he didn't think he was
doing anything wrong he explained to us
that he wanted to be famous and he
didn't think it was a problem he was
arrested on felony charge I don't think
he actually bought it I think he was
charged he was arrested Oh get a load of
this guy's face yeah if anyone's gonna
lick ice cream and put it back here's
your boy you're faint I mean well this
is closer you're gonna get right here
right now what how is licking ice cream
gonna make you famous well go rob a bank
or something I don't know
he was charged with criminal mischief
that is not kind of the coolest charge
ever criminal mischief no good for
tampering with a product before he
purchased it an unlawful posting of
criminal activity for notoriety and
publicity mm-hmm went down hard they
threw the book at him
criminal mischief we're moving right
along here
whoopsie-daisy Whoopi Goldberg also
known as whoopsie doop see have you ever
known anyone named whoopsie or Whoopi no
is that a real name Whoopi because you
also know what B means sex like making
whoopee oh really it's like an old-timey
is that her real name Whoopi Goldberg
that's such a bizarre name when I never
thought I don't think that's for real it
is it's her real name or wait no it's
carrot it's a Karen yeah it's Karen yeah
Karen's boring whoopee
whoopsie doop see ya there's a sketch in
Tim and Eric where they called her whoa
whoopsie Goldberg yeah and then she
wouldn't trip and they would go whoopsie
Daisy
so forevermore I call her whoopsie
whoopsie Goldberg also Goldberg's like a
Jewish name how that's just whoopsie
Goldberg her real name is care Karen
Johnson from Karen Johnson the whoopsie
Goldberg huh
that's a hell of a stage name damn do
people still do stage name or is that an
old thing I think so she'll do do you
think she would have ever been famous if
her name was Karen Johnson think about
it I don't Karin Johnson is sounding
like a lawyer whoopsie Goldberg
I feel appropriated like is that
cultural appropriation for her to be
named Goldberg because that's a Jewish
as it gets named Kenny Johnson is like
she's not getting it a nurse lawyer and
so bella thorne you guys know as a model
she here let me pull up some pictures
here I think there's been a meme about
Bella Thorne for a long time of like
when's she gonna do nudes people always
say that because she does wear very
provocative pictures of herself on
Instagram stuff but you know she's a
young girl and she's attractive and
she's fit so she you know she she's a
model you know it happened recently yeah
that a hacker got a hold of some nude
photographs that were on her phone
similar to the high hack that's been up
until celebrities and she decided to
release them herself on her Twitter
account basically to take the power away
from this hacker that was trying to
blackmail her saying like hey pay me the
money or I'm gonna post your note so
she's lucky all post them myself
here's her statement she said I guess we
can't clearly we can't show it no but
you can use your energy nation that's
wait should we read that or was it just
it was such a statement okay I mean she
just I think this was part of it she
just posted it was like her topless and
it's up on her Twitter still so if you
want to you know see some titties there
there she said yesterday as you all know
all my [ __ ] was hacked for the last 24
hours I've been threatened with my own
nudes I feel gross I feel watched I feel
someone has taken something from me that
i only wanted one special person to see
he has sent me multiple nude photos of
other celebs he won't stop with me or
them he will just keep going for too
long I let a man take advantage of me
over and over and I'm [ __ ] sick of it
I'm putting this out because it's my
decision now you don't get to take yet
another thing from you I can sleep
tonight better knowing I took my power
back you can't control my life you never
will here's the photo he's been
threatening me with in other words
here's my boobies so here [ __ ] you and
the last 24 hours I've been crying
instead of celebrating my book
while doing my book press oh yeah the
FBI will be at your house shortly so
watch your back watch your [ __ ]
back which is true by the way the last
guy that hacks was the fastening had the
FBI got him good
so don't I would not be [ __ ] around
even if you got these man yeah don't do
that [ __ ] you will go to jail
that's a guarantee you will eventually
go to jail the FBI man they don't [ __ ]
around they'll find you
so anyway well anyway the controversy
with whoopsie-daisy comes up what did
you think about her move I think it's
great I mean what else can you do right
I mean it's important it's I think she
did a great thing I think it was very
serious again felt awful we do one of
her options you know it was she probably
didn't want to post it but look I think
what she did was was was a great move
yeah you know [ __ ] that guy and she did
take the power away cuz yeah okay well
[ __ ] off now what you have is worthless
yeah so yeah I said I think it's smart
well I support it I mean it's a shitty
situation of being yeah but like she
said she was a prisoner to this creep
that kept texting her that's just a
nightmare like someone has your phone
number their texts I've been in that
situation before they didn't have my
pictures of me or anything but just
someone who has got your number and
they're texting you and stuff is just so
it feels so violently right but on top
of that to have your nude photos and
beep I mean that's just disgusting so so
you know props to her I think it's a I
think she handled it well I don't know
much about her backstory but I don't
know apparently she's been through a lot
I don't know what she referenced someone
else some other relationship so whoopsie
doopsy makes what is in my opinion a
whoopsie Daisy
and on the view which is one of the
dumbest shows of all time which a bunch
of out-of-touch old women argue about
god knows what they're all obsessed
they're all intolerable it's it's the
trashiest show on television and that's
coming from a guy who cannot wait to
watch The Bachelorette tonight so here's
a clip of what whoopsy doopsy had to say
by releasing the photos herself is this
the way to do whoopsie-daisy used to be
comedian now she's on the view yeah what
the hell happened her sorry what they
say that was so hilarious I was busy
interrupting her power by releasing the
photos herself is this the way to do it
oh she's fully clothed here yeah yep
dumbass I saw the picture of her news I
have to be honest if I had that body I'd
post them at the Food Emporium
that's not the point that is so not the
point
that's why is she wearing sunglasses
probably because she's got [ __ ]
cataracts cuz she's 80 okay but this is
almost like if a guy said that it would
be so sexist they would be talking about
it on this show about how sexist it is
of guys yeah that's not the point
I mean hello if a guy said that his
career would be over yeah
you know pretty amazing how a show women
are so so insensitive
they're clapping they love that they
love that they love that joke
round of applause this is a segment on
the show called hot topics you can see
in the bottom left she's wearing gucci
sunglasses too by the way I just it just
saddens me these kids that they have to
go through this I guess is the age of
social media but you know for someone to
sort of extort her and threatened her
with posting these these pictures I just
you know it it's I just feel that if you
don't you don't say I'm gonna put them
in listen if you're famous I don't care
how old you are you don't take pictures
of yourself in one person but she said
listen when they're hacking you they're
hacking all of your stuff so whether
it's one picture or a million pictures
once you take that picture yeah it goes
into the cloud and it's available to any
hacker who wants it and if you don't
know that in 2019 but this is an issue
you you I'm sorry your age does not you
don't get to do this like anymore you
don't get to do and I just make a hard
copy and put okay whoopsie you don't get
why she angry first why is she so angry
about that instead of being angry about
the person that put it up or that was
distorting her right but also also Belle
never said she never complained about
like oh I can't she was I can't take
nude photos she was simply saying this
guy is blackmailing me he's trying to
have power over me and I'm trying to
take it back yeah but regardless her
point is that if you're famous or even
really she kind of even says if you have
nude photos at all yeah you're not
entitled to any privacy because it's
2019 yeah I mean this is one stupid
[ __ ] sick dude
they probably fished her or something in
an email scam and and somehow
whoopsie-daisy has made it Belle's fault
yeah I mean it's it's it's an awful take
and it's so weird on a show like this
you I think there would be a little more
understanding towards her I don't know
let's just find it so well the one girl
angry why don't why she's so angry she's
like pissed off about it the other girl
was like got railroaded who was trying
to defend her but her tone is like when
they're hacking you like they're hacking
all of your stuff so Daisy the idea to
you know make sure it's on the cloud
yeah I don't know that it's exactly like
that doesn't know anything all that
happen is people are getting in through
phishing scams they send you an email
that looks like yeah I get those all the
[ __ ] time there if you're don't know
much or if maybe you're just not paying
attention that day it's easy yeah you
log in and then they just keep your [ __ ]
whoopsie-daisy has probably done that
ten times but nobody wants to see her
[ __ ] can you imagine the note of
whoopsie Daisy that's why she's so
pissed god you she probably looks like a
you probably couldn't even tell where
her tits start or end do you know what
I'm saying Gila take that picture it
goes into the cloud and it's available
to any who wants and if you don't know
that in 2019 this is why are you so
angry at her you you I'm sorry that I
know I think I know what she's trying to
say you know but that is such a such an
awful take to sale and like on
television where you have you have
actual influence over people I don't
know well sure I understand what she's
trying to say is like if you take nude
photos and especially if your celebrity
in this day in here you got to be
careful yes but again Belle's not even
complaining about that she's simply
talking about
one guy yeah so she's she's missing the
point and blaming her for I mean she's
entitled to her privacy she stole a
human being I'm here you know it the
[ __ ] you don't get to do it just make a
hard copy and put it in a frame and send
him why does it have to be the hard copy
is that the person who has made the
picture appear on you think who also has
a copper yes sir wait what that was
genius were they serious she's that why
don't you just put it in a frame I was
like oh it's a stupid joke and then
whoopsy goes seriously but then the
other lady goes oh I see what you add a
touchhole lady and then this is John
McCain's daughter I learned who is the
conservative voice and when they start
talking politics man you want to [ __ ]
put your head through the wall to
receive that back when I was dating used
to get it all the time right I will say
Rihanna said in 2009 she had leaked
photo she said they were my boyfriend at
the time you don't send your boyfriend
naked pictures then I feel bad for him
now I will say okay whatever then what I
love these women are the worst
I don't know they've completely moved on
to it I gotta finish this that's it I
know that I again you got to be a
comfortable with it being I just assume
everything I send a screenshot well and
set everywhere but I will say but you
cannot be surprised that someone is
she's not surprised she doesn't like
being blackmailed
woopsie doopsy Daisy Floop see ya
whoopee cushion Goldberg
anyway my uh my heart my heart goes out
to Belle who bravely pulled out on Bella
see I'm confused with the whole you got
Belle Delphine Bella yeah what can we
get it straight on the pronunciation I
don't know you know
whoopsie whoopsie Daisy and then Belle
got upset oh the pur spelling is
different well here one hold on they're
spelled two ways here in the dock once B
know and once b la it's it's Bella with
an A yes well that explains why so here
she responds and she's very upset I'm
not gonna lie I want to say that I feel
pretty disgusting you know I feel pretty
disgusting won't be knowing everyone's
ceiling you know my [ __ ] and and I just
want to say that you're watching this
interview made me feel really bad about
myself and and I hope you're happy I
really do it really hope you're so
[ __ ] happy because I can only imagine
all of the kid - it's hard to watch yeah
he's very upset but I agree if I was her
I would feel this because she's so angry
and so much anger towards her or no this
is the victim in this generation no
let's not forget that I don't know why
she was so yeah angry at her and
whoopsie-daisy has not made a
apology which is a whoop of apology
issued by whoopsie I can't get over her
name whoopee oopsy doopsy should I I
mean it's just this she's very yeah I
don't think we need to watch it she
cries and you can imagine um there you
have it so I have seen her boobs as have
you seen her boobs
mhm yeah they're out there it's weird
too because I feel bad that it's up
there but also at the same times like
whatever
yeah it's boobs you know just yeah I
mean right exactly right in yeah you
right
yeah wasn't there another story I wanted
to wrap up we got whoopsie-daisy we got
ice cream challenge
oh no we did it all in the face craze
there you go we're on fire so we got a
lot of this Friday we're gonna be in
we're gonna really Friday we're going in
all business I'm gonna clear this dock
out what you said last Friday people
were calling us out
were they yeah a little bit well this on
Friday it's all business we're gonna be
calling it the all business cast
everyone have fun today was it a good
show it's pretty good I enjoyed that
presentation thank you very much to us
I'm thinking thank you for the
compliment I got the horses in the back
so I'm gonna back come by you alright
well that's it we'll be back on Friday
with another episode h3 not a podcast
podcast h2 experience h3 show h3 do we
need to worry about casts behind we just
realized we're not in the hey I got the
waters and I'm a alright guys I hope you
have a terrific week get out there keep
your heads up keep shaking your dicks
just grind through it get through it you
know stay up positive just [ __ ] get
it done get what to do what's got to get
doing and we're gonna be back on Friday
to have more laughs some more gas to
usher in the weekend but we all get to
put our feet up and enjoy because the
life's a beautiful thing it's hard work
sometimes it's tough work sometimes but
eventually there always comes a day
where you're gonna have a good day and
you're gonna be get to put your feet up
and you can be happy that you did all
that work because now you're satisfied
because you know you're a productive
member of society and your feet up
knowing that you had a huge productive
day and that you know what life ain't so
bad right ela amen amen brother
so we will see you guys on Friday and we
just
you know we're just so appreciative you
know it's just so great that you're all
here bye everybody
[Music]
[Music]